avanza la investigación de las
autoridades mexicanas por el atentado
que sufrió reconocido periodista Ciro
Gómez Leyva el pasado 15 de diciembre el
secretario de seguridad de la Ciudad de
México anunció la detención de 11
sospechosos y dio luces sobre las
posibles causas del ataque esta célula
criminal está relacionada con diversas
actividades delictivas como homicidio
extorsión a comerciantes y narcomenudeo
el caso de Ciro Gómez es uno de varios
México es uno de los países más letales
para los periodistas en el mundo según
la organización de reporteros Sin
fronteras incluso más que países en
guerra como Ucrania según reporteros Sin
fronteras al menos 11 periodistas fueron
asesinados en lo corrido de 2022 por su
labor de informar mientras que la ong
artículo 19 contabiliza que fueron 12 la
mayoría fueron asesinados después de
revelar vínculos de los gobiernos
locales y el narcotráfico pero los
reporteros responsabilizan al presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador no solo por
no medidas para protegerlos sino por
acosar a los medios de comunicación
críticos con su gestión durante lo
ocurrido el mandato de López Obrador los
actos de intimidación y hostigamiento
contra periodistas han aumentado un 52%
durante el primer semestre 2022 respecto
al mismo periodo de años anteriores
según cifras de artículo 19
al homicidio y la intimidación se suma
la desaparición según reporteros Sin
fronteras hay 27 periodistas
desaparecidos y en ninguno de estos
casos se ha llevado los responsables
ante la justicia por lo que la impunidad
es del 100%
la mayoría de las desapariciones se
concentraron en solo 10 de los 31
estados de México